spring is a season of new beginnings
making it the perfect time to pick up a
new hobby oh I love this story JC is
live at Friendly Hobbies with more on
the world of remote controlled Vehicles
Hey JC
hey Kendall Mercedes first off Mercedes
I want you to wear the shoe I think you
should walk around with a Derek Jeter
shoe it's something very special that
you have here and speaking of special it
is special here uh we have this is this
is Brian he's with friendly Hobbies
thanks for being here today thank you
again for coming uh this right over here
this lineup of vehicles here is this a
great entry level when it comes to RC
cars they are they call these Bashers
and it's really a great start for
anywhere from a eight-year-old kid to a
50 year old guy under 300 everything in
the Box battery charger radio everything
you need charge the battery go out on
our Bass track and start jumping this is
a great thing you buy this for the
family buy everything because you're
buying for the kids you're outside in
the front uh thrown in the house in the
street playing with the remote control
car and you have the latest in
technology as well nothing spin around
here you have VR control this vehicle is
really really cool first person view
he's in the goggles so he is sitting in
the driveway there's a camera down here
that's seeing everything in front of it
that's amazing isn't it cool and it's
the latest and greatest technology and
if you can see it it's super HD like
super high quality we got tanks as well
the Ripper fast tank oh it's really cool
let's move down here because if we move
our way down here this is kind of more
of the advanced stuff look at this
amazing suspensions how fast does this
go this is gonna go 60 miles an hour 60
miles per hour
you could you could drive it with it
this guy has a giant lawnmower engine
and a 32cc lawnmower okay about 10
seconds here there's a helicopter flying
down here okay and there's so much stuff
we cannot be contained inside the store
coming up we're gonna go outside
friendly hobbies and we put some of
these vehicles on the true test that's
when the track that you have outside yes
awesome we have so much more coming up
from friendly Hobbies I'll send it back
to you guys in the studio